let's go next to
um why don't we go to victor
from indiana you're on the air hi david
so i was wondering how married are you
to the idea of
a social democracy or having a social
welfare programs uh under the framework
of capitalism
do you think social i'm i'm married i'm
i'm married to it but i have a prenup
and an annulment clause
so i could get out if it got ugly i see
got it no i mean sorry i i cut you off
so you're saying
i it sounded like you were saying how
married am i to social democracy
rather than socialism uh
sort of i guess my main question was do
you think socialism or even something
like communism
is feasible for a human society like
maybe like a couple hundred maybe
like i don't know like a thousand years
down the line or do you just think that
like
capitalism is pretty much the best we
got right now it's not worth talking
about
okay so here's where i'm different from
many other
uh commentators on this issue lots of
commentators you would go to them and
you would ask that question
and some people would say communism
is an inevitability it's just a matter
of when
and there are others on the right and by
the way you've got a horrible horrible
hiss coming through and if we could deal
with that it would it would be a really
great thing
yeah um then you've got people on the
right
including trump i mean trump said it
during his state of the unions
that states of the union addresses
whatever
trump said we will never be a socialist
country i am not
going to pretend to tell you that
something definitely could or couldn't
happen
a thousand years down the line if you
asked anybody in the united st
there was no united states a thousand
years ago if you asked people a thousand
years ago
in 2021 would there be something like
the united states would we have the
technology we have would we have the
culture we have
nobody would have predicted this a
thousand years ago and so
i have no idea i i don't i think that
right now
everything has led me to my current
beliefs
which as you state fall under the
umbrella of social democracy that's
where i am right now
is it possible that things will happen
in the next 200 or thousand years where
in a thousand years
uh the the plant planet earth is a
socialist
planet is a communist planet or there
are many communist countries
that that are flourish yeah it's how
could i say no how could it so
i just think that we are so bad at
predicting the future
that it's certainly possible uh and
if that happens i i don't know what the
path
to it would be
that's a fantastic answer thank you so
much david all right my pleasure great
having you on and uh that's a that's an
ugly hiss there that was happening
i'm glad we were able to get it at least
briefly dealt with